[Música]
Annie se encuentra frente a una escalera
de oro donde el Dios con cabeza de
chacal Anubis pesa su corazón contra una
pluma de avestruz puro Annie fue una
persona real una escriba de la ciudad
egipcia de tebas que vivió en el siglo
XIII antes de Cristo y aquí representado
es una escena de su libro de los muertos
un rollo de papiro de 24 metros diseñado
para ayudarle a alcanzar la inmortalidad
tales textos funerarios fueron escritos
originalmente solo para los faraones
pero con el tiempo los egipcios creyeron
que la gente normal también podía llegar
al más allá si tenía éxito en el
tránsito
el viaje de Annie comienza con su muerte
su cuerpo es momificado por un equipo de
sacerdotes que elimina todos los órganos
excepto el corazón la base de las
emociones la memoria y la inteligencia
luego se llena con llamada natrón y
envuelve en Lino empapado en resina las
envolturas se tejen con amuletos para la
protección y se rematan con un amuleto
de corazón de escarabajo que será
importante más adelante el objetivo del
proceso de dos meses es preservar el
cuerpo de Annie de forma ideal con el
que su espíritu con el tiempo pueda
reunirse pero en primer lugar el
espíritu debe atravesar el duat o bajo
mundo Este es un reino de vastas
cavernas lagos de fuego y puertas
mágicas todos vigilados por las bestias
temibles serpientes cocodrilos y
monstruosidades Mitad humanas con
nombres como el que baila en la sangre
para empeorar las cosas ated el Dios
serpiente de la destrucción se esconde
en las sombras esperando tragarse el
alma de Annie afortunadamente Annie se
prepara con la magia contenida en su
libro de los muertos al igual que otros
egipcios que podían permitírselo Annie
incluyó en su pergamino hechizos o
raciones y códigos que pensaba que su
espíritu podía necesitar
equipado con este Arsenal nuestro héroe
atraviesa los obstáculos repele los
actos de los monstruos y sigilosamente
evita a Pep para llegar a la sala de
maat Diosa de la verdad y la justicia
aquí Annie se enfrenta a su desafío
final es juzgado por 42 dioses
evaluadores que deben ser convencidos de
que él ha vivido una vida recta Annie se
acerca a cada uno dirigiéndose a ellos
por su nombre y declara un pecado que no
ha cometido entre estas confesiones
negativas o declaraciones de inocencia
proclama que él no ha hecho llorar a
nadie no es un espía y no ha contaminado
el agua pero realmente Annie vivía una
vida tan perfecta no del todo pero ahí
entra en acción el amuleto del
escarabajo del corazón inscrito con las
palabras no atestigüe en mi contra
precisamente para que el corazón de
Annie no lo traicionara Recordando el
momento en que escuchó a sus vecinos
pelear o lavó sus pies en el Nilo ahora
es el momento de la verdad de ani el
peso del corazón si su corazón Es más
pesado que la pluma cargado por las
malas acciones de Annie será devorado
por el monstruo
parte cocodrilo parte leopardo parte
hipopótamo y Annie dejará de existir
para siempre
pero Annie Tiene suerte su corazón se
juzga puro ra El Dios del sol lo lleva a
Osiris Dios del inframundo que le da la
aprobación final para entrar en el más
allá en el campo sin fin y exuberante de
cañas Annie se encuentra con sus padres
fallecidos Aquí no hay tristeza dolor o
ira Pero hay trabajo por hacer como
todos los demás Annie debe cultivar una
parcela de tierra lo que hace con ayuda
de una muñeca que fue colocada en su
tumba hoy en día el papiro de Annie
reside en el Museo británico Donde ha
estado desde 1888 solo Annie sabe lo que
sucedió después de su muerte pero
gracias a su libro de los muertos
podemos imaginar lo feliz atendiendo sus
cosechas por toda la eternidad
[Música]
Cómo era la vida en el Antiguo Egipto
para aquellos que aún se encontraban en
la tierra de los vivos siga con este
video a la doctora en sus rondas diarias
mientras atiende a sus pacientes o
descubra con este video la historia de
una de las primeras gobernantes de
Egipto Y descubra por qué casi fue
eliminada de la historia